in the first video and Oilers method we
walked through an example where we were
trying to approximate the solution to y
prime is equal to Y using the initial
condition start when X is equal to zero
y equals one and you were probably
thinking to yourself well it's very nice
that Sal was doing that by hand and it
felt very home home-brewed but this
looks like something that would be a
good job for computers and if you were
thinking that you are right and that is
why I took a little time last night to
actually write a computer program that
implements Euler's method and so what I
want to do in this video is one show you
how to use this program I had and it's
sitting out I'll put an annotation on
this video so that you can click write
to it but it's sitting in the tutorial
on Khan Academy that that that is about
Euler's method and so let's first talk
about how to use this thing so this
first thing this first variable right
over your X step this is how much we
want to step this is how much we want to
increase X by for each when we want to
find each next point in our
approximation so in our right here X
step is 1 we could make this 0.5 we
could make this 2 we could make this
point 0 0 1 is as we see it in the first
video the lower the number here the more
precise of an approximation we're going
to get then these next two variables are
things that you might want to tweak
these are the initial conditions this is
the starting X and when we're at the
starting X we're assuming that the
particular solution will contain that
starting Y so the way it's set right now
it says hey the point 0 1 is in the
particular solution and if we go a
little bit lower this is the function
slope at point I guess I could have
called it derivative at point as well or
dorset an genjo tangent slope at point
those would have all been legitimate
names for this dysfunction but this is
really where where I define what the
differential equation is and so you see
it says like it just says return Y right
over here what it's saying is what it's
going to return is the slope at that
point and you pass it an X and a Y and
then it'll give you the slope of the
point so this is saying that the slope
at that point is equal to Y or another
way to interpret interpreting it is is
that Y prime is equal to Y and
this is the way it's defined now the
differential equation that we looked at
in the first introductory video that at
any point the derivative is going to be
equal to Y and since we step by one we
see that where the point 0 1 our slope
is going to be 1 until our next step
until we increase our X by 1 we get to
this point now our slope is 2 we
increase X by 1 and then our Y goes up
by 2 now we now our slope is 4 we
increase X by 1 we increase Y by 4 now
we could do a different function here
you could say that dydx is equal to
negative x divided by y and we would get
something like this if we just take if
our X step is just 1 if we have this
initial condition our initial condition
could be something like could be
something like that and you say even
with a next step of 1 something as
course is that we're getting a pretty
good approximation right over here and
if we want to get a better approximation
we could make this smaller 0.5 it's even
better if we wanted to get even better
0.1 and you might have noticed something
that just happened here this thing got
wacky as we got as we started dividing
by as we got as we started getting close
to dividing by dividing by 0 and this is
a reminder that this is really just an
approximation tool we're not
analytically finding the actual solution
we're just stepping from you know x
equals 0 to x equals 0.1 to x equals 0.2
and we're using the slopes at each of
those points and were you able to you
figure out the slope based on this
function to to figure out what their
next x and y should be so I encourage
you to play with this it's actually a
lot of fun you can see how you can see
how you get a much better approximation
as you let me go back to what we
originally had you can see how you get a
much better approximation as you get so
as you get your X steps being closer and
closer and closer to zero so this is
you'll notice now when you just we have
a next step of 0.1 at x equals 1 this is
getting pretty close to e it's really
doing good it was probably doing a
pretty good job of simulating of
simulating the
the exponential function y is equal to e
to y equals e to the X so the main
things to know about this is your X step
these right over here are your initial
conditions your x and y and whatever you
put in here you're going to say that
dy/dx is equal to that notice I say
assumes that your differential equation
can be expressed as Y prime is equal to
a function of x and y which is also a
function of X and so whatever you put
here that's essentially your function of
x and y of X so if you have y prime is
equal to negative x over Y you put
negative X divided by Y negative x
divided by Y over in all of this is
actually noise I'd actually have to
raise the initial condition here to do
something like that and if you want to
now know how this program works if you
want to modify this and I encourage you
to modify it make it better because so I
just kind of hacked this together last
night
I'll now explain what the rest of the
program is doing so these are all the
variables for kind of establishing for
drawing the graph paper this is our
minimum X minimum y maximum X maximum Y
they kind of fall off the page right
over here
you have our x and y offset if you
change it notice if you change your x
offset it shows how much we move to the
right of the left the y offset it moves
everything up or down the background
that's just the background color that we
are the background color for our canvas
then the X scale is really just trying
to say well how many four how many of
the pixels result in kind of one
incremental step in X or one incremental
step in Y and actually I probably could
have tweaked this a little bit better to
factor in the offset and that's probably
one of the reasons why I'm falling off
the screen but anyway you can modify it
if you like
these next two functions are really to
just map between x and y coordinates and
pixels so that's that then this is the
color of the actual grid and you can see
I could change that
I can change the color of the grid to
whatever I like I like something what's
a reasonable level of contrast so I'll
leave it there and then these two things
this draws the vertical lines and then
labels the numbers down here you see the
C this draws the vertical lines this
this labels down here note
it starts at x-men it goes up to X max
this does the same thing for the
horizontal lines so this right over here
is going to go so it starts at the Y min
goes up to the Y max draws a bunch of
lines and also labels the y axis so
that's really just kind of the setup and
then this is the actual function that we
call in order to draw in order to draw
our approximation and it makes use of
slope at point so for any point you're
starting your start you start your exit
init X initial X you start your Y
initial Y and then you say look while X
hasn't gotten to our maximum X yet
figure out or draw draw a point at that
point and actually we don't mind X might
not even need that I could comment that
out it doesn't change it really that's
actually my first iteration I have
actual let me take that out I'm going to
take I'm going to take that one out
or I'll leave it in for now this you can
you can modify it as you see fit and
then it figures out the slope it figures
out the slope at that in that current
X&Y so it uses that function so it's
saying okay let me input that X&Y
and then it figures out what the
derivative is at that point and so that
it uses that slope to figure out what
the next x in the next yr the next x is
just going to be x incremented by the
Delta that you pass to it the next y is
going to be the Y the current y plus the
slope times the Delta and then it just
draws a line from the current X to the
next or the current point XY point to
the next XY point and then it makes the
next x1 it makes the next X and the next
why the current X and the current Y and
then it just keeps on going and going
and going and then finally this is
actually where we call where we call
that function and I use the variable X
step that we defined earlier on it you
know 0.1 but if I change this to just if
I just change this to 1 you see that
actually makes the change and I can
actually draw multiple approximations on
the same screen
and that actually might help us
appreciate that actually might help us
appreciate
how our approximation gets better as we
get a little bit more granularity so
let's say let's draw an approximation
approximation and instead of having a X
step or a Delta X of 1 every time let's
have a delta X of 0.5 and so you see it
there the Delta X of 0.5 it gate got
gave me a more accurate representation
and I can let me do our one more just
just show how all this works stroke let
me change the color so for the next line
color let me make it I don't know I'll
make it this kind of this green blue
color and then let me draw whoops not
straw draw approximation notice I have
to capitalize the a draw approximation
and I'll make this one even more fine so
there you go that was even a better
approximation so the blue one is the
most is the most accurate one and you
can do this with a bunch of ones you can
do it if we could do it with what we saw
in the very first video where we're
approximating Y is equal to e to the X
well in that case what the slope at a
point is equal to the y coordinate Y
prime is equal to Y and our initial
condition is 0 1 and you see the blue
one is getting really close to Y is
equal e to the X but you could play with
all sorts of you could play with all
sorts of neat things here so we could do
things like so we could say that Y prime
is equal to I don't know X plus y what
does that do what if we did X minus y
well that actually is that's actually a
pretty neat one we could change our
range we can make our x max let's say we
want to like zoom in a little bit here
let's make our x max equal to 4 and now
you get a little bit more fine-grained
here and then you could you could change
our initial conditions what if the when
X is equal to 0 Y is a higher Y and so
you could see how your different
approximations change so anyway
hopefully you found that interesting I
encourage you to modify this and
understand this because the whole point
of our Euler's method is it's a
numerical method it's it's to use
something like a computer in order to
approximate solutions